es uno de los rostros de la lucha contra
el sida en India lungante que es
seropositivo lleva dos décadas haciendo
campaña para que las personas con VIH
tengan acceso a los medicamentos
antirretrovirales en el país si se toman
diariamente estos comprimidos detienen
la replicación del virus que ataca al
sistema inmunitario el resultado es que
el virus es indetectable y no puede
transmitirse a otros
mi mujer es seropositiva cuando nos
casamos no quería tener un hijo pero mi
esposa insistió en tenerlos después de
dos años comprobé mi carga viral tres
veces y era indetectable cada vez ahora
tenemos dos hijos que son cero negativos
un tratamiento que el gobierno
distribuye gratuitamente a un millón y
medio de seropositivos en el país pero a
pesar de estos avances Parece que la
epidemia vuelve a aumentar en India
según un informe del Ministerio de
sanidad publicado en 2021 2,4 millones
de personas viven con VIH cifra que no
ha dejado de aumentar en los últimos
cinco años y que no se tiene según este
médico
por ley Los médicos tienen que comunicar
a las autoridades el número de casos
positivos las autoridades por su parte
tienen que acudir a nosotros para
recoger esos datos debe haber visitas
periódicas desgraciadamente en los
últimos años no ha habido seguimiento
por no hablar de las poblaciones
marginadas a menudo alejadas de las
estructuras sanitarias en la
Circunvalación de Nueva Delhi esta
ambulancia ofrece pruebas de detección
este hombre tiene 23 años tiene que
responder a algunas preguntas de
antemano
en un minuto su prueba rápida Resulta
ser positiva el objetivo declarado de
esta ong es examinar a las poblaciones
prioritarias las trabajadoras sexuales y
sus clientes los consumidores de drogas
o los jornaleros que vienen del campo
para encontrar trabajo en la ciudad
India se ha propuesto frenar la
propagación de la epidemia para 2030 en
su territorio un objetivo que parece
difícil de alcanzar